bienvenidos de nuevo vamos a retomar lo
que dejamos pendiente porque teníamos la
corazonada de que algo teníamos que ver
con estos cambios de signo verdad esto
tenía que ver con el signo de la y al
elevarlo a sus distintas potencias y
bueno todo esto salía de la serie de
maclaurin de coseno de x + seno de x
vimos que lo que tenía y tenía mucho que
ver con el seno de x
en su expresión en serie y bueno vamos a
hacer un ligero experimento bueno no es
un experimento pero pudo haberlo sido de
qué pasa cuando elevamos el ala y x y
digo que no es un experimento porque yo
ya sé a dónde lleva verdad pero bueno la
y la hemos definido para que y cuadrada
sea igual a menos 1 pero lo que no hemos
definido es cómo elevar a un número
complejo dijo sabemos elevarlo a
cualquier número pero realmente no
sabemos qué hacer con esto así que lo
que vamos a hacer es tratar a la iv como
si fuera cualquier otro número qué pasa
con la y cuándo
se convierte en parte de un polinomio
eso sí lo sabemos porque sabemos elevar
y a cualquier potencia muy bien de hecho
también para eso construimos la iv para
que pudiéramos resolver cualquier
polinomio y así tener las raíces de un
polinomio que incluso no tuviera raíces
reales bueno lo que vamos a hacer es
sustituir y x
en esta serie de mclaren que está acá
arriba y bueno sabemos que la derivada
de a la x es la misma para cualquier
enésima derivada así que vamos a
sustituir simplemente y x en esta
expresión perfecto simplemente en vez de
poner x vamos a poner y x así que el
primer término es 1 el segundo pues va a
ser y equis y ahora el tercer término
pues es cuadrada por equis cuadrada y
donde y cuadra bueno déjenme describirlo
así nada más y por equis cuadrada sobre
2 factoriales loops me faltó un 2 aquí
y luego sumamos y al cubo por x al cubo
sobre 3 factorial + más que sigue más y
a la 4 y a la 4 x x a la 4 entre 4
factorial más y a la quinta potencia por
x a la quinta potencia sobre 5 factorial
y bueno no tengo por qué seguir adelante
se va repitiendo el proceso elevando a
distintos a distintas potencias entonces
esto equivale a poner uno más y equis y
ahora que equivale y cuadrada pues y
cuadrada dijimos que era menos 1 y esto
multiplica x cuadrada sobre 2
factoriales ahora y al cubo es menos y
menos y por x al cubo sobre 3 factorial
perfecto y ahora y a la 4 es otra vez
una verdad así que simplemente sumaremos
1 por equis a la 4 sobre 4 factorial
y bueno vamos a hacer el último caso que
equivale a las 5 pues es y x x a las 5
sobre 5 factorial y así continúa la la
serie entonces tenemos algo interesante
de repente tenemos algo muy parecido a
lo que teníamos n esta expresión sólo
que hay una diferencia una gran
diferencia vamos a comparar esto con a
la equis
vamos a comparar coseno de x seno de x
con el ala y x perdón vamos a comparar
estas dos cosas que estamos enmarcando
aquí tenemos una y luego tenemos menos x
cuadrada entre 2 factorial realmente son
los mismos y luego en x al cubo los
signos están bien pero tienen una y
luego x a la 4 entre 4 factorial son
iguales pero en x a la 5 tiene otra y
así que la diferencia entre estos dos es
que en el segundo todos los términos que
implican seno tienen una y correcto
tienen una y que podríamos en un
principio pensar que estamos
multiplicando el seno de x por i en su
ser en su expresión en serie entonces
estos que enmarque son los términos
correspondientes a seno de x en esta
representación la diferencia entonces es
que todos los términos que tendría el
seno de x llevan una y multiplicando
delante de ellos
de hecho el signo está bien lo único que
cambia es que estamos
así que como podríamos reescribir esto
lo podremos hacer como una suma de
coseno y seno donde el pse no lo estamos
multiplicando por verdad déjenme borrar
esto para tener una imagen más clara
realmente podríamos escribir el ala y x
y x
y bueno vamos a separar los sumandos que
sí tienen la y de los que no lo tienen
de hecho vamos a poner primero los que
no tienen es decir los términos reales
cuáles serán pues era uno menos equis
cuadrada sobre 2 factoriales baja más x
a la 4 sobre 4 factorial menos x a la 6
sobre seis factorial y otros términos
así continuamos hasta el infinito estos
fueron los términos reales este en
realidad no es simples no es un menos
son son realmente puntitos es bueno a
ver no quiero hacer esto vamos a
rehacerlo es que se ve como un signo
menos ya no puedo deshacerlo pero bueno
esto significa que si seguimos sumando
ok esos son los términos reales
esencialmente y luego los términos
imaginarios éstos serán bueno todos
están multiplicados por una y verdad
entonces déjenme sacarla ahí y vamos a
escribirlo como y x
y cuáles serán los términos eran x menos
x al cubo entre 3 factorial es más vamos
a sumar más x a la 5 sobre 5 factorial y
menos x a las siete sobre siete
factorial y así seguimos sumando hasta
el infinito correcto
bueno está a poco no es la
representación de maclaurin del coseno
de x y del mismo del mismo modo a poco
esta no es la representación del seno de
x pues sí claro y probablemente lo que
realizamos en la pantalla anterior donde
les mostré que los términos imaginarios
correspondían a los términos del seno de
x y todos los reales corresponden al
coseno de x entonces cuando lo
comparamos si ustedes ya creyeron en mí
que la representación en series de la x
coseno de x y seno de x realmente eran
iguales a pesar de ser una suma infinita
entonces llegamos a esto a lo siguiente
qué es una idea extraña y sorprendente y
mística que es a la y x
que alá y x sea igual al coseno de x mas
mas i veces el seno de x y esto es a lo
que se le llama la fórmula de hoy leer
por cierto en la letra i viene de hoy
leer que de hecho se deletrea
lr pero así se pronuncia así que no sólo
hemos encontrado una relación entre este
número extraño y místico y mágico
y las funciones básicas de trigonometría
que hemos definido como la relación de
los lados de los triángulos rectos sino
que ahora vamos a relacionar esto con
otro número místico y mágico que hemos
usado muchas veces y ahorita vamos a ver
tenemos este número y que además aparece
de ser la raíz cuadrada de menos 1 pero
vamos a llevar todo esto un paso más
allá y esto va a explotar tu mente si no
es así entonces no tienes emoción alguna
así que si tomamos esto fundamentalmente
nos estamos diciendo nos estamos
diciendo que cuando llevas algo a la
potencia de
y que podemos sustituir esto en la
representación de mclaren bueno podemos
decir que esto es una proposición
bastante razonable pero qué sucede si
tomamos algo de la potencia de i pi es
decir vamos a evaluar
a la ip bueno por ahora lo hacemos
porque estamos diciendo que estos dos
lados son iguales entre sí así que
simplemente será cuestión de sustituir
déjenme hacer esto en un color diferente
porque me en ese ser visible
a la ip pues será igual a sustituir este
lado derecho con pi que será josé no más
y veces seno de pi seno de pib y que es
el coseno de pib pues esto es menos uno
y el seno de pi es cero así que
obtenemos la expresión ea la ip igual a
menos 1 o 1 negativo
a esto es increíble también podríamos
escribir a la ip 1 igual a 0 y está una
vez más es impresionante cualquiera de
ellos debe hacer que cuestione lo que es
la realidad porque tenemos el número pi
que es la relación de una circunferencia
y su diámetro el número que viene del
interés compuesto continuo además
tenemos el número y que es la raíz
cuadrada de menos 1 la unidad imaginaria
baja y además vienen todos juntos de
esta fórmula incorpora todos los números
fundamentales de las matemáticas pero
vienen de direcciones de direcciones
diferentes aunque podemos probarlo y
decir que esto es verdadero les diré que
probablemente nadie en la historia de la
humanidad comprende la razón de por qué
es así esto es un vistazo del tipo de
orden que hay en el universo